what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar back at it again with another
demonstrator video as promised i
mentioned in the how strong is tank and
uzoi video that i will get started on
the next video as soon as we hit 4 000
likes on that one and we hit that within
24 hours i also asked if you wanted
shinobu or mitsuri next and most people
chose mitsuri from what i can tell so
here we are for the shinobu fans never
fear though same will go for this video
so spam that like button until it gets
to at least four thousand five hundred
likes i repeat four thousand five
hundred to unlock how strong is shinobu
besides smashing that like button is
yorichi energy and passing his muzon
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future demonstrator videos
that's just the way it works and while
you wait for the next demonstrator
season and video to come out feel free
to check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist which includes
videos on every demon moon every pillar
every demon slayer and much more link to
that is in the description now a quick
thank you to this video sponsor girl
cafe gun girl cafe gun is a brand new
shooter rpg development game that
integrates tps combat and live 2d
interaction use multiple fighting skills
and strategies by switching between
three characters in one team and
outsmart your enemies in style this game
combines the two core elements of
shooting games shooting and dodge you
can command the soldiers in the squad to
repel the opponent while avoiding a
barrage of bullets from enemies immerse
yourself in beautiful graphics powered
by live 2d build your dream team by
collecting character cards and form an
intimate bond with your favorite waifus
you also get to share personal moments
and private messages gifts and more girl
cafe gun offers a stunning audio visual
experience featuring top tier voice
actresses and compelling plot lines and
who doesn't want to have a hot secret
agent waifu by their side and if that's
not enough you can run your own virtual
cafe with customized decorations and so
much more check it out right now by
clicking the top link down in the
description and don't forget the gift
code girl cafe gun is a brand new game
so if you start playing now you will get
a head start on the competition and if
you use my link and gift code you will
be directly supporting this channel so
try it out for yourself now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all mitsuri is the love pillar and
the 19 year old best girl of the series
let's start with her series debut and
move through her feats of strength to
uncover exactly how strong mitsuri is
when she's first shown aside from her
outfit being one of the best things ever
she's also shown to be the only hasha
with a blushing face as most of the
others are wearing pretty stoic
expressions while other hashira like
tangen and even rengoku want to execute
nezuko and even tangita for protecting
her at first mitsuri feels bad about
killing such a cute kid the thought is
too much for her showing that she's much
more sympathetic and kind-hearted than
the average hashira she's also attracted
by strength and reliability as a heart
is drawn over her head as she notices
snake hashira iguro who's chilling on a
tree as coolly menacing as a snake to
use her words this is one of my favorite
ships in the series and love to see that
it starts off right off the bat with a
heart from mitsuri that being said
mitsuri has compliments for most of the
guys and even for shinobu like when she
said tunjuro was cute and that giu is
adorable for being all alone and keeping
his distance and that sonamy has even
more scars than before and that makes
him rugged and that shinobu sounds angry
and that's rare and thus cool hearts
frequently appear around her head during
these moments of admiring others but
that makes sense for the love hashira
the hearts don't always have to signify
romantic feelings mitsuru tells the
other hasha that they should wait to
hear the master's opinion before trying
anything rash like hurting tanjiro and
nezuko and she's the only hashira so
distraught by sanami hurting nezuko that
she can't help but sweat and bring her
hand to her mouth so from the beginning
mitsuri arguably made the best first
impression a gorgeous lovely dovey
positive and compassionate person who
was on the side of our protagonist more
than anyone else except giu and giu had
ample time to grow attached to tundra
and nezuko compared to her plus as i
mentioned she's gorgeous and her in her
outfit is life itself so all in all it's
hard not to love the love hashira right
from the start but the question remains
how strong is she to answer this
question let's fast forward to the fight
against upper moon for han tenggu where
mitsuri plays a vital role mitsuri is
shown running towards the scene after it
looks like tanjo and nezuko have been
defeated by upper moon 4. she rescues
some swordsmiths from a fish monster
quickly and they are amazed by her speed
and strength one even says she's a
strong hashira but he forgot because
she's so cute a good reminder that just
because mitsuri is super attractive and
i mean super attractive doesn't mean
she's not strong too mitsuri goes on to
save another swordsmith and we get a
good sense of her blade which is very
unique it's flexible and can move more
like a whip than a sword making her
movements harder to predict and the
longness of the blade also increases her
range as well although this seems like a
pretty outlandish weapon it's possibly
inspired by the real life urumi a sword
with a flexible whip-like blade that
originated in india even one of the
sword smiths she is saving can't help
but remark how weird her sword is she
goes on to beat the giant monster with
one move love breathing first form
shivers of first love gotta love the
names of these specific attacks and you
have mitsubishi to thank for them
because as with tangent she created her
own breath style when she realized she
couldn't fight her full potential using
it and goku's flame breathing which she
learned first after upper moon 4's anger
clone absorbs han tengu's relaxation
clone sorrow clone and the light clone
they form the much much more powerful
hatred clone called zohaku 10. when
tangero first sees this hatred clone he
starts sweating thinking that he can't
breathe and that this clone is so
overpowering that his heart hurts
against this clone that can use all the
powers of the others tanjuno nezuko and
genya almost get beat for good they're
all captured and tundra is about to be
crushed to death by a wooden dragon when
mitsuri comes in and saves tundra by
slicing up a giant wooden dragon head
mitsuri even says she barely made it in
time further suggesting that tundra was
on death's door and has mithri to thank
for his life mitsuri tells them to leave
the hatred clone to her and as the
wooden dragons launch a lightning attack
zohakuten is surprised to see that
mitsuri can cut his attacks so like
akashi from naruto she earned the title
of lightning cutter at this point we're
told a bit about her sword her beloved
sword is extremely thin and flexible the
speed of her technique surpasses even
tangent oozues a very significant detail
if you've watched my recent how strong
is tangent video where we emphasized his
insane speed we're further told that the
speed of mitsuri's techniques is made
possible not only by the flexibility of
her powerful katana but by her own
flexibility and incredible range of
motion it's added that her katana is
difficult to use and will cut anyone
else who wields it it was made just for
her a weapon which only she can use that
is such a cool detail and it shows how
one of a kind mitsuri is far more than
just a pretty face she continues to cut
the wooden dragons and the attacks that
they launch at her she's already doing
better than tanjiro nezuko and genya
combined could do and keep in mind these
characters are all stronger than they
were when they faced upper moon 6 with
thang and uzoi mitsuri manages to make
her way through the hatred clones
countless striking trees attack and she
even closes the distance enough to get
her blade around his neck tanjuro is
blown away by how fast she is but it's
no use because as tanjo knows and
mitsuri doesn't that's not the upper
moon's real head so what could have been
game over for the demon actually ends up
being a huge advantage for him and he
launches a compressed sound waves attack
at point-blank range against mitsuri who
is right in front of him at this point
there's no doubt about it this attack
takes a big toll on mitsuri as we can
see but as the hatred clone points out
it should have been much much worse he's
shocked that she absorbed a full attack
and that she's still whole for the demon
it is inconceivable that she could
survive that it's then pointed out that
mystery is special in yet another way
and wow does she ever have a lot of
things going for her we're told that she
has a special constitution her physique
belies her muscle density aka despite
her slim figure she has insane muscle
density that makes her much more durable
than most people and much stronger than
most people even if most people look
much larger than her zohaku ten gets
excited by this thinking that eating
superior flesh like this leads directly
to gaining strength he goes to punch her
head in and then mitsuri's life passes
before her eyes we're further told
during this flashback that her muscle
density is a whole eight times that of a
normal person we even get an
illustration of how her slender arms
would actually look on a normal person
with equal muscle density and let's just
say they'd be very very jacked at 13
months old mitsuri could already lift a
stone that weighed 15 kilograms or 33
pounds and her pregnant mother was
shocked for the first time in her whole
life when she saw this since her body
was special she ate more food too she
could eat more than three sumo wrestlers
combined so if you were to date this
gorgeous woman it would cost you a lot
in restaurant bills luckily when we jump
back from the flashback mitsuri is not
dead kendra and the others helped save
her and they're determined to protect
her because in their view she's the one
with the greatest potential who shines
the light of hope they can only win if
she lives mitsuri is touched by their
words and actions and promises to beat
the hatred clone upper moon or not we
find out that mitsuri loves the
demonstrator core so much because they
saw her strength as a blessing not a
curse like most civilians she went from
having to hide her true self to being
valued by everyone to being thanked by
the people she saved and iguro even gave
her her long striped socks i don't know
why she remembered this detail but i
love it because it shows how important
iguro is to her mitsuri explains that
she would worry that it wasn't okay for
a girl to be so strong and that people
would treat her like she wasn't human so
in fear she suppressed her strength in
the past but she tells us not anymore
with a determined look she promises to
protect everyone mitsuri although she
was already so strong continues to
improve while focusing on raising her
heart rate higher and speeding up her
blood flow so she can be faster and
stronger and she succeeds in occupying
the hatred clone well enough so that all
the others succeed in escaping and start
searching for the main body keep in mind
it was already said that her techniques
were faster than tengen's and now the
hatred clone starts commenting on how
she's moving even faster than before as
she continues to improve before our very
eyes at this point we see that mitsuri
has awakened her demon slayer mark an
especially cute one around her neck and
if you didn't know demon stare marks are
like going super saiyan for demon
slayers it increases all of their
abilities including speed strength and
so on demonstrator mark mitsuri is good
enough to anger the hatred clone because
she's too good and as a result he can't
send a beast after tanjiro nezuko and
genya his only consolation is that he
believes since she's a human she'll have
to run out of strength eventually and
that's when he'll beat her eventually
we're told on a cover page that mitsuri
has been using a lot of big moves so her
strength won't last much longer meaning
that if tanjiro kenya and nezuko weren't
going after the real body she would lose
eventually against upper moon 4. however
you're usually not expected to beat an
upper moon alone except if you're
muichiro and it's upper moon 5. so the
fact that she is able to do this well
speaks volumes about her strength tundra
succeeds in destroying the original body
and we find out that nezuko can survive
in the sun meanwhile just as mitsuri
cries as she can't take it anymore and
that it's killing her the hatred clone
and his attacks vanished letting her
know that tundra and the rest succeeded
and unlike with tangent mitsuri didn't
suffer any serious long-lasting injuries
like losing a limb against this higher
ranking upper moon fast forward to
chapter 182 and the team is taking on
muzon the strongest demon with yoshido's
help they succeeded in tricking muzon
into believing that mitsuri and igoro
were finished by taking control of
nakime's vision thus mitsuri catches
muzon off guard when she suddenly joins
the fight he's having against tanjong
gil unfortunately despite catching him
off guard mitsuri doesn't succeed in
harming the demon king of pop and she
claims she's never been so shocked
mitsuri is not stoic when it comes to
facing muzon although she is strong she
can't help but think of how scary muzon
is and how she's never seen a scarier
demon she feels like she's gonna die on
the spot she's so scared and wishes
gyome the strongest pillar would get
there soon against muzon you start to
see mitsuri lag behind the other
remaining hashira keep in mind shinobu
is dead by this time having sacrificed
her life to help stop upper moon 2 and
tangent is practically retired and not
fighting against muzon mitsurigiu and
iguro all attack him together when
yusuru finally manages to get everyone
outside of the infinity castle it's the
hardest fight of their lives no doubt as
even when they cut muzon he regenerates
the moment they cut him so if they slice
his neck the part they sliced first is
already healed by the time the sword
exits the other side muslin is crazy
strong but what can you expect from the
strongest demon between the three
fighting hashira mitsuri is the one that
looks like she'll be taken out first but
luckily gyomei arrives as she wished and
stops muzon's deadly attack the very
strong salami the wind hashira also
joins the battle at this point then once
more after muzon's attacks get even
faster mitsuri is the one who thinks
that she can't see him at all and is
relying on intuition and luck to dodge
she thinks to herself that she'll be the
first to fall even though she's barely
helped at all and although she obviously
did help her prediction of being the
first to fall is correct she's the first
one to get hit badly and gets a portion
of her face sliced off to igoro's horror
iguro takes her to safety and puts her
in good hands telling her that she's
done enough even though she wants to
keep fighting she begs igoro not to get
himself killed as tears rain down her
cheeks after mitsuri gets taken out
iguru turns his blade red and this leads
to a domino effect as gyomei sanemi and
giu's blades turn red as well red blades
like marks are associated with improved
offense and muzon's regeneration is
slowed down when a bright red blade is
used to cut him so unfortunately mitsuri
did not get to partake in these red
blade power ups after muzon is defeated
a very very injured iguro goes to
mitsuri who is on the verge of death
because of her injuries she no longer
feels any pain which is how she knows
she's dying while mitsuri thinks she
didn't help at all igoro insists that
her bottomless cheerfulness and kindness
saved many people including him and she
should be proud i love the fact that
saving people is put into a different
context here it doesn't just have to be
physically it could be emotionally too
and throughout the series mitsuri
evidently saved many people in both ways
we finally get their confessions of love
which i love to see mitsuri cries saying
she's so happy she says she cares about
igoro so much and that meals always
tasted best with him because he looked
at her with so much affection she begs
him if they were reborn as humans for
iguro to take her as his bride and of
course he agrees because that is what he
wanted all along you don't just go out
of your way to randomly give the girl
socks if you don't want to marry her in
this life or the next and they do get
their wish they are reincarnated in a
later life and get their happy ending
and it was one of my favorite parts of
the final chapter however that is a
topic for another video so back to the
question how strong exactly is mitsuri
the love pillar well very strong she is
a hashira because she excelled among
demon slayers her technique was even
faster than tengen's and that was before
she awakened the demon's layer mark
which made her even faster and stronger
while shinobu wasn't strong enough to
cut off a demon's head mitsuri was
exceptionally strong because of her
crazy muscle density she could not only
cut a demon's head off but survive
attacks that would have left most people
in shreds and while tengan was hurt
badly losing an arm and an eye by upper
moon 6 even after having helped from
tanjoy nosquezo and his wives mitsuri
was able to hold off upper moon 4's
insanely powerful hatred clone long
enough for tundra to take out the real
and much weaker body and she suffered no
lasting serious injuries obviously she
did eventually get defeated against
muzon the strongest demon and in that
fight she showed that she couldn't quite
keep up with geyu igura sanemi and gyome
so all in all as i explained in my
hashtag rank for week is the strongest
video link in the description i would
put mitsuri above shinobu and tangen but
below the other hashira still it must be
kept in mind that these hasha are an
especially strong batch of hashira and
as we discussed in the tangent video
tengen was stronger than the many
hashiragutaro fought and beat before
even if tengan was among the weaker
hashra of this insanely talented
generation and i always want to
emphasize in these videos that there is
much more to characters than just
strength as iguro did such a good job of
pointing out don't ever think i'm hating
on a character just because i rank them
lower in terms of strength because many
of my favorite characters are not the
strongest characters but that is it for
this one in the end mitsuri is not only
best girl but also the strongest female
hashira if you did enjoy this video and
want to keep the demonstrator videos
coming chill the orichi within and smash
that like button as mentioned if we can
get 4
500 likes i repeat 4 500 i'll get
started on my detailed breakdown on
shinobu and her abilities and overall
strength besides remember smashing that
like button is your ichi energy and
passing its muzon energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future demon slayer videos that's just
the way it works and while you wait for
the next demonstration and video to come
out which will be very soon feel free to
check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist which includes
videos on every demon moon every hashira
every demon slayer and much much more
link to that is in the description and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you